what is this thing is it a motorcycle is
it a Segway it's actually called a rhino
have you ever seen anything like this no
well YouTube things on YouTube how
exactly do you define the Rhino it's a
electric unicycle we're still struggling
with how you define it Chris Hoffman is
the former auto engineer behind the
Rhino
he says it's something between an
electric bike and an electric motorcycle
the Rhino accelerates when the driver
leans forward and slows when they lean
back it stays upright thanks to software
that knows where the center of the earth
is keeping the bike and the rider
balanced this actually relies on your
own sense of balance and gives you just
enough stability so you can pilot the
bike with its fat Pirelli a squeal and
Ducati red detailing the Rhino is track
and road ready in appearance only
how fast is baby go yeah we're gonna
keep it at 10 miles an hour because we
want to be you know pedestrian-friendly
Hoffman got the idea for the Rhino seven
years ago when his daughter asked him to
build a one-wheeled motorcycle she saw
in a video game but the Rhino almost
didn't make it out of their garage he
was all personally funded at the
beginning yeah I was out of pocket money
guy I ended up selling my house and
moving it a little fourteen through
fourteen room and I was down on my last
thousand dollars before we got our first
investor a 1.3 million dollar injection
allowed Hoffman to start production the
first rhinos will start shipping to
customers later this year and cost fifty
three hundred dollars each at that price
it will take 3.5 years for the company
be profitable I'm feeling great is the
Rhino just a novelty item we don't know
I mean s we're trying to find out this
year
you